[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur la page facebook de france 3
bourgogne pour ce rendez vous spécial
législatives en saône et loire nous
avons amené notre plateau ici au creusot
nous remercions d'ailleurs la
municipalité du creusot et l'arc la
scène nationale du creusot nous nous
intéressons cet après midi à la 4e
circonscription la bresse et tournus un
débat en partenariat avec nos confrères
du journal de saône et loire et vous
pouvez bien sûr réagir et commenter ce
débat sur facebook douze candidats en
lice dans cette circonscription et parmi
eux nos six invités en commençant par
cécile untermaier bonjour vous êtes la
députée socialiste sortante élue en 2012
catherine gabrel bonjour vous porter les
couleurs de la république en marche dans
cette élection maxime thiébaut bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le candidat du front
national après avoir porté jusqu'à la
présidentielle les couleurs de debout la
france
stéphane graux bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le candidat des républicains élus d y
investit par ces partis une investiture
a l'air que vous n'avez pas eric michoux
bonjour exactement jour et michel
chambon bonjour vous êtes la candidature
de la france insoumise tous les
électeurs ne vous connaissent pas encore
forcément toutes et tous nous vous
proposons donc de vous présenter de nous
dire quelles sont vos motivations va
falloir être con si vous disposez de 30
secondes chacun en commençant par vous
cécile untermaier présentez vous merci
merci à vous et bien vous m'avez élu en
2012 dans une circonscription dans
laquelle je vis depuis 30 ans avec ma
famille issue de la société civile sous
préfète magistrate administrative mon
travail à l'assemblée nationale a été
reconnue puisque je suis classé 11e sur
577 députés et en tête en acidité
j'ai également au niveau local su régler
des dossiers difficiles
je pense à la clinique du val de seille
à la sous préfecture au marché de
louhans mais aussi à l'éducation à
l'école et j'ai inventé les ateliers
législatives citoyens pour associer les
citoyens à ma politique
je veux que cette terre soit une terre
d'innovation et de réussite
merci cécile untermaier catherine cabrel
bonjour catherine cabrel
je suis j'ai suivi une formation
universitaire en économie et en droit et
j'ai travaillé pendant de très longues
années dans le public et le privé maire
de royer depuis 2005
je suis également été présidente de la
communauté de communes du tournugeois de
2008 à 2014 et g
et belle idée mon engagement vraiment au
service de mon territoire
donc pendant cette présidence de la
communauté de communes nous avons
réalisé des projets de proximité utiles
comme la maison de santé du tournugeois
une pépinière d'entreprises et une
ressourcerie merci catherine gavrelle
maxime thibeault bonjour alors maxime
thiébaut je suis juriste des
collectivités territoriales j'habite la
circonscription parce que j'y suis né
que c'est ma vie j'ai fait mon collège
mon lycée dans cette circonscription
voilà c'est là où j'ai mes racines
alors je m'engage pour deux raisons la
première est laid nationale c'est à dire
que je veux rendre à mon pays sont sa
souveraineté sa souveraineté nationale
parce que je pense qu'on peut pas être
libre si on dispose pas de l'ensemble
des pouvoirs et on peut pas dessiner
l'avenir de nos enfants c'est notre pays
n'a pas les pouvoirs d'agir c'est à dire
la monnaie les frontières le budget
l'économie la politique étrangère et
autres et mon deuxième qui est le
deuxième engagement que j'ai les locales
c'est-à-dire que je veux défendre porter
les projets à paris et en tant que
juriste des collectivités territoriales
je sais que j'en suis capable
merci stéphane graux bonjour bonjour eh
bien d'abord comme la majorité des
français je travaille je suis chef
d'entreprise une petite entreprise
artisanale basée à ormes dans une
commune dont je suis le maire depuis
trois ans commune que j'apprécie pour
son côté rural pour ça son dynamisme
et puis avec anthony vadot qui est maire
de branges
eh bien nous sommes très attachés à
notre territoire l'élection
présidentielle qui vient de se dérouler
démontre une aspiration profonde des
français à vouloir incarner le
renouvellement et j'estime que à 36 ans
est bien j'incarne ce renouvellement
merci eric michoux bonjour merci de
m'avoir accueilli malgré que je ne
représente pas un parti politique je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la parole est
donnée aux gens de terrain je suis
quelqu'un d'expérience j'ai l'âge
d'avoir de l'expérience je suis chef
d'entreprise j'ai redressé et repris
ensemble de sociétés dans une très belle
à chalon sur saône s'appelle escoffier
où on a maintenu 50 emplois et créer
plus de 100 emplois indirectement donc
s'il s'agit de parler d'économie et de
retour à l'emploi j'ai des connaissances
en la matière et puis j'ai un engagement
important qu'elle suit
demers depuis plus de dix ans et
président de l'agglomération délégué à
l'économie du grand chalon et je
développais aussi dans ma commune un
ensemble de choses qui vont vers le lien
social vers la petite enfance les aînés
la création d'une résidence seniors
d'une école de cuisine beaucoup de
choses et je pense que enfin dans cette
assemblée nationale il faut dire jean
terrain qui connaissent ce qui se passe
exactement pour pouvoir remonter ces
idées là merci merci avec michou michel
chambon militante associative je me suis
rendu compte qu'on avancera pas vers le
progrès social sans le pouvoir politique
c'est pourquoi je défends l'avenir en
commun notre programme s'adresse à tous
chacun peut nous rejoindre en trouvant
la porte d'entrée qui lui convient ma
mission dans ce contexte consistera à
donner du poids politique à la france un
soumise à l'assemblée nationale de telle
sorte que notre gouvernance nationale
puisse bénéficier à notre
circonscription
merci michel chambon merci à tous les
six d'abord de vous être présenté
on va rentrer dans le coeur de ce débat
avec un chapitre politique on n'aurait
peut-être pas fait certaines années
parce que les lignes étaient claires
cette année c'est peut-être après la
présidentielle plus compliqué vous allez
nous dire où vous vous situez en
commençant d'abord par les deux
candidats de droite on va dire stéphane
graux eric michoux opposition soutien au
gouvernement il ya un premier ministre
de droite
alors vous et tous alors d'abord je
pense qu'il faut attendre le résultat
des élections législatives pouvoir se
positionner j'espère que je me
positionnerai dans une majorité
évidemment si celle ci n'est pas obtenue
il va falloir travailler en bonne
intelligence avec le gouvernement il va
falloir travailler
pas forcément dans une opposition
systématique
je crois que les français ont une vraie
défiance maintenant à tous types de
sectarisme à tous types de
bipolarisation de la vie politique
on a dépassé ça on est en 2017 et je
pense que l'élection d' emmanuel macron
a au moins eu ce mérite c'est bien de
décloisonner le paysage politique
donc pour ma part pas de d'opposition
systématique
eric michoux et bien moi je suis dans le
constructif je suis dans le constructif
parce qu'en fait ce que je vais
représenter c'est la bresse le val de
saône est on les joue un tout ce qui
sera bon pour la bresse le val de saône
et le ton dès juin je voterai ce que
sera proposée par emmanuel manqueront
tout ce qui sera bon pour l'entreprise
parce que sans une économie moderne une
économie forte
ya pas de développement social pas de
développement sociétal pas de force
politique indien je vole députés votent
aussi des choses qui concerne
l'international la défense et ça c'est
pas le tournugeois bien évidemment mais
moi je suis un député terrain qu'est sur
cet axe là qui est là pour défendre les
gens du territoire
et si effectivement mais il ya tellement
d'autres choses sur la médecine on le
verra thaler japon très un regard qui
sera lui à mon expérience mais mon
expérience comme jette alors c'est
l'économie c'est l'entreprise c'est le
territoire et je suis là pour défendre
le territoire au plus haut niveau
catherine gabrel on n'entend pas
d'opposition systématique
on entend aussi intérêts dus de la
circonscription
tout le monde est dans la baie sur la
même ligne oui c'est vrai que tout le
monde est sur la même ligne mais la
seule qui soit investi par la république
en marche c'est moi j'ai été choisi et
je suis fier de l'être donc j'entends
exercer son rôle de députée vraiment
d'une façon la plus sereine possible ce
que je connais bien je suis entièrement
investi sur ce territoire depuis de
longues années et ce sera mon credo
pendant ce mandat
cécile untermaier c'est quoi votre
position on disait dans les débats
précédents de la journée que entre la
ligne amont et l'alim case meubles par
rapport à emmanuel macron il ya de
grosses différences alors vous vous et
où je suis déjà la députée de la
circonscription et c'est cette étiquette
d'abord que je revendique elle travaille
que j ai fait ensuite je pense
excusez moi mais je pense que cette
question elle n'a pas vraiment beaucoup
de sens en ce moment parce que le
président de la république lui-même
parle et à la droite et à la gauche
et moi je suis une femme de gauche une
famille il ya déjà des candidats
socialistes qui s'affirme dans
l'opposition et manuellement moi je
nomme je ne m'inscris pas du tout dans
l'opposition c'est ce que je viens de
vous dire c'est que
on doit s'inscrire dans la construction
ayant député responsable
je dois bien sûr je suis soucieuse pour
vous de réussir ce quinquennat et j'ai
davantage ici de bien connaître emmanuel
macron j'ai été rapporteur spécial de sa
loi croissance et activités sur une
partie extrêmement importante qui
concerne les professions réglementées et
on a travaillé ensemble on a pu discuter
ensemble et 50% de son texte a été
modifié de sorte que il a été adopté à
lui-même l'unanimité de notre majorité
donc je sais où je vais avec qui je vais
travailler avec mes valeurs mes valeurs
de gauche ainsi que je voulais dit
michel chambon pas d'équivoque pour vous
la france est soumise est clairement
dans l'opposition à manhattan sommes
laissé l'opposition de gauche
les présidentielles n'ont rien réglé
nous avons toujours les mêmes urgences
sociales et écologiques
il est donc important de ne pas donner à
emmanuel macron la majorité qui lui
permettrait de passer en force avec ses
ordonnances
il faut savoir il faut que nous soyons
très nombreux pour faire un bloc soudé
il faut savoir qu'avec 15 députés on
peut demander une commission d' enquête
parlementaire avec 58 députés
on peut s'opposer aux ordonnances en
votant une mission sont une motion de
censure
avec 185 députés nous ne pouvons
demander un référendum en vue d'une
constituante et avec 289 députés tout
simplement vous en version volante pose
en plus les chiffres
maxime thiébaut vous avez changé de
parti mais toujours dans l'opposition
bien sûr je suis dans l'opposition et
vous savez aujourd'hui on a un nouveau
clivage politique
d'un côté on a les patriotes qui sont
incarnés par le front national par
debout la france et on a d'un autre côté
les mondialistes qui sont aujourd'hui
incarnée par la république en marche et
deux vieux partis politiques qui sont en
train de mourir qui sont dans une macro
compatible il faut être honnête dont je
ne vois pas l'opportunité de leur
candidature parce qu'on sait très bien
que de toute façon ils vont deuxième
tour sauter le candidat dans marche
et donc si vous
voulait pas donner les pleins pouvoirs
monsieur macron si vous ne voulez pas
que demain la csg aux demandes que vous
ne voulez pas que notre pays soit encore
plus libéralisés que les classe moyenne
souffre davantage
vous allez être obligés de voter pour
des candidats patriotes qui sauveront la
démocratie parce que le vrai drame est
monsieur macron c'est quand même la
fédéralisation de l'europe c'est-à-dire
la soumission de la france à des
intérêts étrangers et je pense qu'il
faut un vote utile le vote utile c'est
front national et je suis désolé mais
les candidats du parti socialiste les
candidats les républicains udi n'ont
aucune opportunité dans cette
candidature
un petit mot on vient de nous faire la
remarque sur facebook des gens qui
regardent l'émission nous disent qu'est
ce que ces candidats peuvent faire
contre le chômage
ça renvoie un des projets des manuels
macron alors vous allez me dire c'est
peut-être un petit peu parcellaire qui
est fait de revoir le code du travail
par exemple est-ce que ça entre vous 6
c'est une ligne de fracture cécile
untermaier c'est une bonne idée de
revoir rapidement le code du travail
alors moi je suis contre les contre les
ordonnances bien évidemment j'ai écrit
un livre sur le parlement du futur le
parlement fort c'est pour que bien sûr
le parlement ne soit pas dessaisie de
ces questions et de ces domaines majeurs
qui sont les domaines sociétaux ou du
travail donc je suis extrêmement
réservée sur le principe même d'une
ordonnance et je pense qu'au contraire
le parlement et c'est sur le toilettage
du code du travail au delà de
l'ordonance parce que les français
finalement est-ce qu'il se fiche pas de
la façon dont on va le faire
bah écoute et ils ont tort ils ont tort
parce que ce camp le camp lors le projet
doit passer au tamis de députés
responsables
il est considérablement enrichie et
s'agissant de la loi travail
nous avions des solutions nous avions
apporté et le 49-3 est venue tout
bouleverser donc moi je veux pas
travailler de cette façon là vous savez
que l'ordonnancé plus violente que le
49-3 puisque le parlement est
complètement des saisies et s'agissant
de la rapidité avec laquelle le texte
doit être voté
c'est faux parce que vous avez des
procédures accélérées qui vous
permettent dans le même temps de
travailler sur un domaine de cette
qualité avec des députés qui s'ils sont
vos élus est rémunéré c'est quand même
pour qu'ils travaillent et non pas
disent oui à tout ce qui est proposé par
le gouvernement
merci c'est souvent le temps meilleurs
plusieurs on a toujours cette entreprise
sur ce plateau stéphane graux le code du
travail
vous êtes pour pour retoucher le code du
travail le revoir ceux proposant des
macros oui absolument absolument
aujourd'hui le code du travail tel qu'il
est est un frein au recrutement
c'est un code du travail qui est
obsolète nous devons permettre aux
entreprises aujourd'hui d'embaucher plus
facilement
nous devons passer enfin à ses 39 heures
en retravaillant ses 35 heures qui ont
été terribles pour la france on est
passé en l'espace de cinq ans entre 2012
et 2017 à plus d'un million de chômeurs
donc le bilan de françois hollande
à ce titre là n'est pas glorieux je suis
chef d'entreprise une petite boîte un de
bien de chez nous comme on dit j'ai
travaillé avec quelqu'un j'ai beaucoup
de difficulté à trouver des apprentis à
trouver des gens qui veulent se lever
tôt le matin et pour moi c'est le code
du travail aussi qu'il faudrait former
en s'exerçant autres chefs d'entreprise
éric michaud de ce fruit d'un travail ça
fait 30 ans que j'utilise
en dix ans il a doublé de volume on est
à trois mille six cents pages nul n'est
censé oublier la connaître la loi mais
c'est impossible à utiliser ça crée un
problème justement de tension dans
l'entreprise où plus personne connaît ni
ses droits et ses devoirs
l'entreprise est devenue difficile à
gérer non seulement font l'abroger ce
code du travail mais faut le refonder
leur fondé sur une base simple comme par
exemple en belgique ou en suisse
trente pages qui donne le squelette de
la relation du salarié et de l'employeur
une relation digne et sincère et honnête
et puis après branche par branche
discuter pour chacune des branches de
comment on l'a ménages est aussi en
partenariat avec l'entreprise parce que
les mieux ceux qui sont le plus capable
d'en parler ce sont quand même les
salariés et les entrepreneurs
merci eric michoux maxime thiébaut sur
ce point là avant qu'on passe puis
locale mais je partage une partie de
l'analyse d'eric michoux sur le cas du
travail en étant très attentif sur le
respect notamment du préambule de 46 de
la constitution sur les droits garantis
aux salariés parce que moi je vois que
progressivement on atteint les droits
des salariés et que les classes moyennes
et populaires souffrent davantage mais
faut pas oublier une chose c'est que si
aujourd'hui on essaye de de donner plus
de flexibilité au travail c'est parce
qu'on est totalement incapable sur le
propre
le plan français de défendre notre
économie moi je suis pour remettre un
protectionnisme économique
je suis pour retrouver la souveraineté
monétaire je suis pour que notre pays
tout d'abord commencé par faire
travailler des travailleurs français au
lieu d'aller faire
produire des marchandises en chine ou
dans d'autres pays ensuite les ramener
en france des marchandises qui ne
respectent pas le code environ le code
de l'environnement où nos normes
sociales et ils sont contraires
finalement l'intérêt général merci
maxime thibault michel sont bons je
suppose que comme vous l'avait déjà
évoqué tout à l'heure j'ai déjà évoqué
je pense que je suis pas sûr que les
travailleurs soient eu d'accord pour
qu'on modifie le code du travail et je
ne suis pas sûr non plus qu'il soit
d'accord pour qu'on que ce soit à chaque
entreprise dans chaque entreprise que
les négociations se fassent
comment imaginer des négociations juste
entre des salariés et un patron c'est
impossible
le code du travail c'est comme les côtes
du lard de la route ça doit être
universel catherine gabrel il ya des
voies des lignes de convergence sur sur
ce sujet là oui alors moi je défends des
dents dans vos réunions publiques de
cette élection
oui je le défends dans les réunions
publiques parce que je pense que ce soit
les entrepreneurs que j'ai rencontré les
agriculteurs que j'ai rencontré et les
jeunes et les travailleurs
on a tous besoin d'une refonte de ce
code du travail c'est un frein constant
à l'emploi allemand bosch aux
négociations entre les différentes
branches et c'est vraiment primordial
que ce soit revue et rapidement et je
pense que le mandat précédent en fait on
a souffert de ce problème qui a traîné
en longueur où aucune solution vraiment
favorable elle n'a pu être trouvé et ça
c'est ce qui à en générer en partie la
fin de quinquennat de monsieur hollande
qui a été très difficile
et là je pense que monsieur macron a
tout à fait raison de vouloir mettre le
programme tout de suite sur le tapis et
de mais je dirais que pour avoir bien
discuté avec en marche la vue de
monsieur macron c'est vraiment
l'écoutent le respect et la
bienveillance et dans ces trois mots et
à tous toute la commande hier tout ce
qu'il entend faire donc il a déjà
commencé à recevoir des gens d
des différents partenaires blanche et ça
continuera je me permets de réagir je
suis quand même désolé attendez on va
faire payer aux salariés une réforme du
code du travail si on veut relancer
l'économie on ferait mieux de baisser
les charges sur les pme tpe elles sont à
33% aujourd'hui c'est aberrant quand on
voit que les amis de monsieur macron les
grandes sociétés bouygues vinci et
autres ne paye soit pas d'impôts 60 %
d'impôts donc moi je suis très méfiant
quand même sur le fait de moraliser
finalement le travail en france alors
qu'à côté on voit des grandes sociétés
qui ne payent pas d'impôts à léon on
n'avance pas ce qu'on voulait vraiment
parler de votre circonscription qui fait
la spécificité de votre circonscription
et on va le faire en partenariat avec
nos partenaires du jour le journal de
saône et loire et benoit montaggioni qui
est journaliste
mon collègue au journal de saône et
loire qui normalement devrait être en
train de me rejoindre sur le plateau
coco voilà voyez le code du travail à
trail est un petit peu benoît on s'était
dit qu'on avait envie de parler de cette
circonscription qu'elle très rural la
bresse retourne jouer avec des
caractéristiques vraiment rien rien il
ya une vraie question sur la braise on
parle souvent c'est la désertification
on a deux villes on a loué on à tournus
et on a un secteur qui est très rural
vous le disiez alors moi j'ai envie de
parler de la santé notamment
c'est compliqué aujourd'hui quand on
habite en bresse de trouver un médecin
généraliste d'aller voir un spécialiste
et j'ai envie de parler avec vous je me
dirigeais vers madame gabrel en premier
vous êtes maire de la commune de royer
prétend il
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour que les
médecins viennent s'installer chez nous
est ce qu'il faut forcément déroulé le
tapis rouge sortir le carnet de chèques
quitte à se faire concurrence entre les
différentes communes comment on fait
pour les faire venir ses médecins je
pense que c'est pas forcément ça la
réponse quand on a construit la maison
de santé du tout en jouant on s'est
aperçu qu'en fait
les médecins étaient plutôt ouvert j'ai
pas mal discuté avec eux et discuter du
problème de la bresse parce que c'est
vrai que sur le tour du jura s'est pas
encore une zone déficitaire mais pas
content la bresse avaient un sérieux
problème de santé publique
et ils m'ont tous dit la même chose en
fait
la bresse c'est pas le problème le
problème c'est l'attractivité du
territoire c'est que la profession
médicale s'est fortement féminisé et que
les femmes médecins ont des attentes
pour leurs enfants pour leur vie
familiale et qu'en fait il faudrait
simplement rendre son attractivité à la
bresse c'est à dire développer des
services rendre les développer la
mobilité parce qu'on s'aperçoit qu'elle
moins en moins de transports publics les
crèches avec les mam par exemple où les
maisons d'assistantes maternelles c'est
vraiment toute cette infrastructure dont
ils ont besoin les petits commerces en
fête qui réclame c'est pas une une
maison de santé avec tous les retours
groupés ça cesse a bien sûr ça les aide
parce que ça leur permet de mutualiser
et d'être moins seul mais ce qu'ils
veulent surtout c'est que quand il
s'installe
il est des services autour c'est une
tome ailleurs pour le parti socialiste
si je me souviens bien vous souteniez
arnaud montebourg lors de la primaire de
la gauche lui avait proposée qui est des
des médecins salariés la sécu généralise
qu'ils soient installés dans les zones
déficitaires est ce que c'est votre
position aujourd'hui pour pour résoudre
ce problème
effectivement il ya un problème de droit
opposable à la santé tout habitant quel
que soit le territoire où il vit à droit
à voir un médecin référent or on est
actuellement dans une difficulté et moi
je dois dire que la médecine de
proximité on a échoué pendant ce
quinquennat on a réussi sur terre
certaines choses mais certainement pas
là dessus
les maisons médicales elle existe
partout dans le territoire le problème
c'est que les médecins soient vont
partir parce qu'ils ont atteint l'âge de
la retraite soit ils ne veulent pas
venir alors que fait-on moi je pose je
pense qu'il ya des mesures au niveau
national qui doivent être prises nous
les avions proposé elles n'ont pas été
acceptées en déposant un amendement
imposant le nom conventionnement de
médecins qui vont s'installer dans des
zones surdotées je pense qu'il n'est pas
normal que la sécurité sociale
soutiennent l'activité de médecins qui
sont en surnombre dans une note dans un
territoire alors que dans un autre
territoire
les citoyens ne sont pas servis par ce
dispositif alors il ya déjà ce point là
est ce que ça coûte cher aux citoyens
par les impôts par les impôts locaux le
nom conventionnement ça va pas leur
coûter cher ça va simplement connaître
maison de santé par exemple la maison de
santé si vous voulez elle coûte cher oui
il faut quand même garantir que elles
soient remplies or il ya des efforts de
l'état et des collectivités locales pour
créer ces maisons de santé mais aucune
garantie qu'elles soient habités par des
médecins donc on doit faire cette
action-là au niveau national c'est clair
ouvrir le numerus clausus mais ça va
prendre du temps
faciliter le multi sites pour les
médecins parce que actuellement on a des
montagnes administratives pour permettre
un praticien hospitalier par exemple qui
souhaitent donner un jour de sa
spécialité dans une maison médicale on
n'y arrive pas j'ai essayé sur tournus
on n'y est pas arrivé
il faut il faut vraiment travailler dans
deux
multiples directions parce que c'est un
problème majeur mais puisque j'ai la
parole je voulais dire que la
circonscription c'est pas quand même que
la zone rurale et on doit pas oublier
chalon nord parce que chalon nord pour y
être allé quand même de manière très
régulière depuis 2012 c'est un
territoire qui est vraiment en
souffrance qui a été aggravée par une
politique d'abandon depuis 2014 par la
municipalité
allez vous promener à chalon nord et
vous verrez que nous avons vraiment des
choses à faire on peut souligner
d'ailleurs que même à chalon même à
chalon nord c'est compliqué aussi
trouver un médecin c'est évidemment
moins compliqué qu'en zone rurale
maxime thibeault vous vous êtes habités
ce secteur de de chalon nord vous si
j'ai bien compris si j'ai bien lu vos
mesures ce que vous voulez c'est faire
revenir les médecins retraités oui une
partie des médecins retraités mais aussi
des jeunes moi je vais augmenter le
numerus clausus et jeux de toute façon
je suis pour établir un service national
et j'aimerais que les étudiants en
médecine pendant leurs années de service
national eye en zone rurale pour pouvoir
comme ça exercer et pourquoi pas
s'installer à terme
mais ce que je ferai aussi c'est de
gérer dans les facs de médecine en tant
que député je parlerai de mon territoire
en disant bah voilà vous pouvez venir
vous installer ça ressemble à ce député
d'à côté il va faire pareil donc allez
vous attirer la personne le fait qu'ils
vont pas dans les facs de médecine les
maires le font actuellement dans le mail
à son origine ternat les maires le fond
mais c'est ce qu'il faut faire il faut
aller voir les gens il faut les
installer
il ya un cadre national qu'il faut
changer ayez un cadre local en faisant
naître une dynamique mon frère est il
n'hésite et rapide sur chalon nord
il déborde de travail et me dit le
problème aussi c'est que on voit quand
même assez rarement des gens pour les
attirer et il n'a pas vu d'élu je suis
désolé qui est venu le voir pour lui
dire bah il faudrait installer ici on a
besoin de toi ça m'étonnerait que vous
ayez des élus qui se dévoue je suis
désolé montée se dévoue mon père se
dévouent pour faire venir un médecin et
remplacé celui de virey-le-grand tu vas
bientôt partir en retraite
stéphane graux est-ce que vous avez tout
d'abord vous des médecins dans votre
commune ou autour
et est ce que la solution c'est le
numerus clausus comme on l'a entendu est
ce qu'il faut qui est tout simplement
plus d'étudiants en médecine pour qu'ils
viennent exercer près de chez vous alors
d'abord oui vous avez je remercie de
poser cette question parce que c'est une
question qui est fondamentale pour nos
territoires ruraux nous avons en bresse
et val de saône en moyenne deux fois
moins de consultations
qu'au niveau national sa veux dire quoi
les gens se soignent mois alors dit
comme ça ça veut dire ça c'est pas que
les gens sont moins malades
je dis c'est que malheureusement c'est
que malheureusement les gens ce dès ce
comment dire ne peuvent plus appeler un
dentiste dès lors qu'ils ont une rage de
dents se résigne à contacter un dentiste
dès lors que ils savent qu'ils auront
deux semaines trois semaines quatre
semaines de délai donc ça signifie qu'on
a une inéquité au niveau médical en
france donc la proposition en tout cas
la mienne
sachant qu'à six membres pour répondre à
votre question nous avions un médecin
roumain
quand même qui est venu alors tant mieux
tant mieux pour ce monsieur mais
aujourd'hui il est reparti on a plutôt
dit que faire moi je pense que c'est au
législateur de décider les maisons les
maisons médicales c'est très intéressant
évidemment si on peut appuyer les jeunes
à s'installer
mais c'est au législateur de décider un
numéro tous clausus géographique en
imposant dans les territoires qui sont
défavorisés et bien des médecins
là où il le faut voilà que ça comme une
profession qui refusent un argument tout
rayonnement tation elle que vous
l'évoquez tout ça depuis 50 ans quand
même et parle mais on roule mais par
celle menée mais on en ignorait russe
clausus partout pardonnez moi et on sait
très bien que la profession de médecin
n'arrive n'acceptera jamais ce la
déréglementation du système la santé
publique n'est n'est pas une marchandise
comme les autres
aujourd'hui on souffre de médecins en
bresse et val de saône c'est un constat
c'est un constat d'échec de plusieurs
décennies de politiques nationales à ce
sujet et ce n'est qu'au législateur de
pouvoir enfin c'est quand même pas la
mort de venir pour un jeune étudiant de
médecine 2 à 3 ans en bresse val de
saône
on a un territoire qui est formidable on
est à une heure et demie de lyon on est
à une heure et demie de genève
alors je fais la promotion d'un
territoire évidemment pour les attirer
ceux qui vont à la sortie des facs sa
part et du bon sens on manque environ
manque en france d'efficacité politique
je pense que c'est tout à fait louable
j'ai posé la question à présent à michel
chaumont alors c'est quoi votre votre
préférence à vous est ce que vous aller
draguer les étudiants à la sortie des
facs ou
ou est ce que vous demandez aux
législateurs de leur tordre le bras en
tendant le bras mais je crois que on ne
demande pas aux enseignants qui passent
là greg et le capes ou est ce qu'ils
vont exercer
moi j'ai vu des agrégés de lyon est
nommé à lille
et ils y vont ils y restent plusieurs
années donc à partir du moment où les
études médicales sont gratuites
je ne pense pas que ce soit absolument
affreux d'obliger les étudiants en
médecine à venir occuper des postes à la
campagne pour éviter les déserts
médicaux
je crois aussi beaucoup ou maisons
médicales ou de santé ou maisons de
santé plutôt par maison médicale c'est
différent j'ai créé à
châtillon-sur-chalaronne avec un groupe
de médecins et des paramédicaux une
maison de santé qui fonctionne
parfaitement qui a attiré des étudiants
qui maintenant reste dont s'installer
dans les campagnes environnantes parce
qu'ils la connaissent
on oblige les des spécialistes des
sages-femmes des dentistes à venir faire
des permanences
si on pourrait justement ne plus les
conventionnés si on le pense qu'il ya eu
ils viendront cilicie course au risque
là voilà je pense qu'il faut être un
petit peu peut-être autoritaire parce
que après tout la santé du peuple c'est
quand même quelque chose d'important et
c'est quand même c'est pas une c'est pas
une horreur de venir en bresse surtout
qu'ici on développe l'attractivité de ce
territoire sont les autres plans et en
particulier le transport
merci monsieur eric michoux à présent la
quasiment la même question qu aux autres
est ce que la solution c'est je sais pas
des dispensaires à l'ancienne avec des
pas forcément l'ancien ailleurs avec des
médecins salariés par la sécu ou est ce
qu'on arrive à attirer les jeunes
médecins en bresse est ce que l'eldorado
du futur pour le l'étudiant en médecine
c'est la bresse ou est ce qu'il faut le
forcer un peu mais c'est évidemment la
bresse le val de saône le tournugeois et
chalon nord évidemment et je passe le
dernier donc c'est toujours difficile
d'avoir quelque chose d'intelligent à
dire après que ces personnalités que
vous exprimer voilà mais alors un iphone
faut apporter un esprit innovant vous
l'avez dit le dispensaire c'est quelque
chose qui est très ancien vous serez à
conclure ça compense pas et je remercie
je remercie le dispensaire c'est quelque
chose qui existe est à très longtemps
qui permettait justement au médecin
d'avoir une structure pouvoir travailler
ensemble à voir multiples compétences
dans un lieu donné
aujourd'hui les médecins souhaitent ou
pouvoir être salarié ou pouvoir
travailler en libéral ce que j'ai
proposé et vous le savez pour l'avoir
développé déjà par ailleurs c'est de
recréer des dispensés aux des maisons de
santé centrale par exemple une à chalon
où une à louhans et autour de ces
maisons de santé avoir des satellites
tels qu'on est en train de faire dans
notre commune qui seront en relation
internet avec cette maison de santé donc
dans le monde qui existent aujourd'hui
il faut être faire évoluer les choses
on ne parle plus en nombre de médecins
numerus clausus je crois démence et 6200
médecin 6300 médecins il faut parler en
compétences on volume de compétences et
comment cette compétence on l'utilisé en
réalité parce que si vous regardez le
travail d'un médecin un tiers de son
travail ça consiste à faire de
l'administratif l'autre tiens ça
consiste finalement un travail qui n'est
pas de la médecine réellement le tiers
où il fait son métier c'est celui ce
métier médecin donc il faut pouvoir
créer ce réseau à travers l'intelligence
artificielle à travers le data pour
avoir une nouvelle manière d'aborder la
médecine
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
dans notre commune merci eric michoux un
tout petit mot catherine gabrel parce
que dans le temps de parole vous étiez
petit peu en retard sur les cinq autres
vous parlez de votre expérience vous
aussi de maisons de santé mais
finalement tout le monde fait ça
aujourd'hui et pour autant la
désertification médicale s'est pas réglé
non mais je pense que il y en a pas
assez sur le territoire et qu'il faut
favoriser en fait les initiatives avec
des plus petites unités
en fait là on a construit pour la
plupart des grandes maisons de des
grandes maisons médicales donc à tournus
c'est vrai qu'à une vingtaine de
praticiens
ça marche très bien il y à toutes les
communes aux alentours qui viennent à
tournus c'est vrai mais je pense qu'il
faut quand même faire de plus petites
unités et les répartir plus sur le
territoire donc dans le plan de monsieur
macron il ya la construction de 1500
maisons de santé et je pense que c'est
important qu'ils aient un député qui est
défendre sa circonscription et qu'ils
aillent au charbon pour récupérer des
maisons de santé sur notre territoire
merci pour cette intervention ce qui
nous a permis de légaliser un peu de
choses près les temps parole de tout le
monde on arrive à la fin de ce débat et
c'est le moment de parler de passer aux
conclusions
en deux secondes chacun dans un ordre
tirés au sort préalablement avant cette
émission merci de respecter cette règle
des 30 secondes et on commence je vous
l'avais promis par vous c'est très
gentil nuit comme vous le comprenez
depuis tout à l'heure j'essaie
d'exprimer que je suis un homme de
terrain et on a besoin de plus en plus
de députés terrain qu'ils connaissent
quand l'expérience alors j'ai l'âge
d'avoir l'expérience 57 ans j'ai trois
enfants
malheureusement j'ai à save j'ai
l'expérience shazam qui va avec
il faudra quelqu'un qui ne soit pas
attacher obligatoirement un parti et
qu'ils puissent se focaliser sur sa
circonscription
tout ce qui sera bien pour la bresse et
val de saône et toi je voterai pour je
voterai tout ce qui est bon pour
l'entreprise parce que quand même
quelque part on a évoqué des choses qui
se prépare en bresse sur les aspects
économiques l'économie en bresse va
connaître des turbulences ceux qui sont
autour de cette table bien connaisseur
de notre secteur salle qui vers des
problèmes économiques il faudra donc
quelqu'un qui connaisse l'économie
l'industrie et la bresse pour pouvoir
aider à ce travail important merci avec
n'échoue cécile untermaier à vous de
conclure avec votre victoire dont nous
avons gagné ensemble des combats
difficiles et je veux continuer dans
cette voie de l'impartialité et de la
proximité et en tant que député
responsable soucieuse pour vous en fait
de réussir ce quinquennat
eh bien je vais travailler pour
simplifier pour faciliter d'initiative
l'information valoriser le travail mais
aussi protéger les oubliés de la
république que sont les personnes âgées
les petites retraites
les personnes handicapées et les femmes
isolées alors ce que je vous demande
c'est de voter vous écarter des
étiquettes ne lisez pas les étiquettes
et votez pour la députée la députée qui
a soutenu le territoire merci cécile
untermaier michel chambon c'est à vous
de conclure la militante associative que
je suis sera confortée par la candidate
élue je joindrai ma voix à celle de la
france insoumise pour annoncer les temps
heureux aux exclus de la richesse
mondiale
participant au gouvernement de la france
je pourrais faire bénéficier ma
circonscription des retombées que
l'avenir en commun distribuera à tous
merci je suis stéphane brosse est un pur
maintenant bien écoutez je vais inviter
les électeurs de la bresse et du val de
saône à faire le bon choix pour cette
élection législative à faire le choix du
vote utile du vote d'une personne qui
n'est pas forcément clivante qui au delà
des partis parce que vous savez quand
vous êtes maire à la table d'un conseil
municipal vous êtes évidemment au delà
de tout vision clivante et partisane
j'invite les électeurs à faire le choix
aussi du renouvellement de la jeunesse
et puis je les invite aussi un peu plus
senti mentalement à faire le choix est
bien de l'enfant du pays qui sort à les
écouter les comprendre et agir en leur
sens merci beaucoup maxime thibeault
c'est à vous de conclure le général de
gaulle disait la démocratie c'est
l'exercice de la souveraineté nationale
sans entrave et aujourd'hui je suis le
candidat de la souveraineté nationale
c'est à dire de notre démocratie de
pouvoir écrire notre avenir de ne pas
être prisonnier d'intérêt peut pas être
prisonniers des amis de monsieur macron
c'est à dire les banques de ne pas être
prisonnier de lobbyistes et mon objectif
filer son plan national de me battre
pour rendre à mon pays sa liberté et
pouvoir dessiner l'avenir de mes enfants
et sur le plan local à porter des
projets des projets que je connais pas
ce que je suis malenfant de ce
territoire
merci maxime thibeault et le tirage au
sort vous a donné la dernière conclusion
catherine cabrol
alors je dirais qu'on est exempt le
président de la république le 7 mai
dernier nous avons fait un choix un
choix d'une france réconciliée apaisé je
pense que là il faut continuer sur la
lancée il a besoin d'avoir une majorité
pour pouvoir entamer tout les modifier
toutes les réformes qu'il a prévu et qui
sont nombreuses et importantes pour nous
pour tous les habitants du mâconnais du
du tournugeois de sennecey-le-grand et
de la bresse et en tant que
et lui débuter je m'engage à m'investir
complètement pour le territoire avec
conviction comme je le fais toujours à
demeurer une élue de proximité et à
jouer pleinement le rôle d'interface
avec vous tous merci beaucoup merci à
tous les six d'avoir accepté le
l'exercice du débat signalons aussi
comme que son candidat sur cette 4e
circonscription de saône-et-loire
fabienne delorme pour lutte ouvrière
semble breen bernadat pour le pc marie
claude colas cordier pour europe
écologie joël janet christiane lumière
pour debout la france et guillaume
ferrand pour lui br c'est la fin de ce
débat
merci à tous les 6 et puis rendez vous
bien sûr dans toutes les éditions de
france 3 et dans les journaux du jsl et
sur le site du jsl si merci beaucoup
benoît merci lyon bonne journée
au revoir merci
[Musique]